this is a first step to establish a
wider wide-ranging cooperation between
Europe and Africa I'm one of those who
believe that we should not look just at
the issue of migration on its own but
rather look also at the huge potential
that Africa has and I think that now the
action plan shows maybe for the first
time the commitment of Europe to see the
relationship flourish let me just say
that the recent development in in
Germany in in Sweden in Slovenia and in
other countries also with utmost clarity
the huge pressure member states are
facing saving Schengen is a race against
time and we are determined to win the
race we launched projects to enhance
employment opportunities in regions of
origin and transit of migrants in east
north and west africa we will double the
number of scholarships for students and
researchers through the erasmus+
programme we will facilitate returns
preferably voluntary by a number of
concrete steps such as African
immigration officials traveling to
Europe to help verify and identify the
nationalities of irregular migrants and
to help implement what we have agreed we
have launched the EU trust fund this
comes on top of EU and member states
development assistance to African
countries of 20 billion euros every year
don't guard global within the global
context of our partnership this summit
in the spirit of responsibility balance
and pooling of our efforts has adopted a
political declaration that is strong and
will be followed by an action plan
expressing our shared
I authored or not vision Papaji